fastfood pizza burger london und gordon
ramsay all diese sachen seht ihr in
diesem video hier vor einer woche haben
wir ein restaurant von gordon ramsay
getestet und heute haben wir einen pizza
und einen burger spot getestet auch in
london viel spaß mit dem video und danke
für eine million abos da kommt noch was
besonderes auf euch zu
[Musik]
kann man die sonne scheint direkt wir
sind nach gordon ramsay street pizza
wunderschöner laden aber wie es die
pizza weihwasser gordon ramsay mit pizza
zwischen nicht so super viel deshalb
erwarte ich bei der pizza nicht so viel
wie beim burger aber ich habe natürlich
trotzdem riesen erwartungen lassen
vielleicht laden ist richtig geil kommt
und viele gerade das konzept erklärt
dann bläst ich dachte erst mal so ps
besondere pizza ganzen bogen hat oder
aber es heißt einfach und kann ihn für
15 pence und das ist nicht viel sondern
trinkt man so viel besser wie man will
[Gelächter]
also wir sagen noch nicht so etwas essen
aber erst mal wurde das schöner lagen
faire preise london das sieht hübsch aus
und ist es wieder so ein neues konzept
decker kennst du das hast du einfach
anhört dass leute mit ganzen pizzen und
laufen man was du eins live gehen wenn
du willst wir haben ja auf jeden fall so
eine peperoni damit kleinere kurs crispy
aber sehr flach er sucht er sucht die
ganze in den rippen hier gehen die pizza
verneigt sich leicht so lieben wirst
aber
weiß man nicht fertig genug kinder oder
es ging heiß her und niederlagen wieder
so wie auch beim letzten test raum
suchen dann holen wir auch nach
allergenen gefragt vielleicht ist es
aber auch einfach üblich ist
[Musik]
sagt ich auf den ersten biss nächste
knusprig aber ich muss erstmal bisschen
beiden problem auch hier der distrikt
ist krass oder wo wir hier sitzen mit
meinem austritt aber siehst du das so
der banker und bewege sich einfach hier
an unsere pizza wirken die erste pizza
das wachsame einer minute tür weicht
einem youtube wir müssen uns einmal
gemeinsam hier im laden bisschen
umschauen
bin sehr gespannt auf den burger laden
ob der ausdruck eines designkonzept weil
das gefällt mir für das was es ist fast
noch besser als bei onkel und das fand
ich auch gut mir das war ja auch ein
bisschen schicker einigen mäßig an
gehabt aber hier ist einfach so passiert
das für stühle projekt so dass jedes
restaurant was garantie auch mal ein
risiko für ist weil er derjenige ist
herumgeht des tors kritisiert die leute
klein macht er nie verkaufen dh er muss
trassen standards weise bieten und das
geht nicht in meinen kopf der pepperoni
vielzahl dem fleisch gerade gebe ich zu
siebeneinhalb und zehn
liegen pizza und auch nicht eine
vegane pizza organe pizza was haben wir
darauf weist berlin maschine so coaches
und ein test oder sehr gespannte gerne
pizza
jetzt sind wir nämlich auch beim
transport ist wirklich anders anders ja
wohl auch ganz für strauß sie kamen ganz
ganz schlecht riecht supergut
superlecker pinienkernen probiert habe
ich schon mal den garten werfen nein
[Musik]
jetzt ist der fan starb dann lag die
andere wahrscheinlich von missionaren
und du solltest sagen dass ich zurück
bin erzählte der krise kennst du hast
dir noch so viel ps haben das so
gummiartige gar nicht über dienste
wechselplatten für mich ein ganzer punkt
besser ableiten muss den kunden leute
das ist meine perspektive auch einfach
wunderschön nicht nur wegen eric merkst
du denn die textur ist eine andere oder
ganz anders vor nicht nur in dem pesto
ist käse drin hast du uns dafür dass wir
hier jetzt so raschen müssen ich will
hier bleiben kündigt aber wir müssen
trotzdem bürgers potter und wir haben
nicht mehr viel zeit
man sieht auf jeden fall das feiern vor
den augen der gäste gekocht wird das ist
so eine zum selbstbewusstsein was damit
schwenkte und einfach so transparent
dass da kein scheiß drin ist mit mir
schon recht gut ich bin gespannt was wir
noch viel besser kriegen und dann ist
auch schon mal ein buch weil er müsste
man auch dem bürger auf uns wirken
lassen und da drei burger jetzt schwer
meine erwartung private
kicken schießen hat das ist schon mal
ganz ganz wild ja das brauchen wir ja
das brauchen wir das lied wir spätestens
jetzt sollte klar sein das ist keine
italienische bezahlen also das ist
einfach ein ansatz den ich auch markt
bei pizza wo einfach das beste aus
beiden welten genommen also du hast du
mit den bühnenboden die bei den
italienischen pizza du hast aber so eine
leichthändige koste die nicht so hoch
geht und nicht nur lustig ist wie man
abhaken und am hals stecken und chorizo
kommen also in
detaillierten nachweis warum ich
nachdenken mag es nur nie geschmeckt
habe okay das chicken ist gar nicht so
stark gewürzt das ist so weil das
spektrum kritik weil sagen wie es anders
sagen sie schmecken richtig gut
da so richtig saftig der das finde ich
noch verrückter und ausgefallen als wir
das eben dann geht es noch mal an einem
punkt und das ist nur neuen konzepten
und ich nur danach kommt nix mehr geht
nicht mit c von zehn pizza oder zehn von
zehn pizza ist die idee ab denn das
wurde
gefragt ob wir müssen hier unter 50
meter
[Musik]
also wieder 15 5 menü auch bleibt mit
dem software ich sogar für kunden okay
das schnell entscheiden was nicht mehr
für eine teilnahme zu schaffen wir
kleinbürger also was sollen wir hier
schon wieder sagen der laden ist wieder
hübsch sehr sehr gut ist ein anderer
stil als geben mir persönlich gefällt er
gerade ein bisschen besser gehst du
diese suite mäßige wir haben dachten wir
an den wänden die lampen sind ein paar
gläschen puzzle ist auch noch wie oben
hängen so led steht also das sieht
durchaus wie so eine schwarzlicht
minigolf paaren restaurant voll aber es
gab
12 64 minuten
54 minuten auf die bewerber salate
snacks oder sind wir im richtigen bürger
ok wird dann unser leben retten wir
waren so knapp davor dem mama wachmann
mittelstädt schauen wir mal rein leute
sollte man sieht die farbe nicht so gut
weil es von oben so blau leuchtet aber
der ist heftig medium ich kann das
erkennen und er ist vor allem saftig das
ist der berühmte bondi bürger aus diesen
viel geklickten video am pult aus seiner
villa tomaten pesto eine große scheibe
fleischtomate die gewürzgurken ist die
schöne schnulze these
ressourcenschätzung apotheke tomatensoße
deiner ich bin gespannt was die frische
von einschuss ablauf und gemüse
diese tomatensoße diese leichte super
das brot schönweiß nicht mehr bloß blick
und das fleisch
sag was ich denke es leider nicht
außergewöhnlich also ich will es gar
nicht laut aussprechen aber das ist so
ein bisschen
was man manchmal wenn man bei sony paar
diensten sondern stellt die eigentlich
kann die bürger hart sagen das ist so
also es ist jetzt wirklich schon als
sich sowohl frisch gebackene sondern
vorbereitungs april
das ist kein fairplay
preis macht die das stimmt allerdings
was den feuchten bis hin und das werde
den ganzen bürger der sonst wirklich
außen teilen ist schon ab auf jeden fall
preis
das sind feiert preis und 10 wir sind
wahrscheinlich fünf mal pilotierte kurs
für cd die man hensel machen spaß zu
essen was auch interessant ist das finde
ich dass sie so diese mcdonnell in fast
food guide gewählt haben in dem wieder
die tür parken was gibt es zu den bürger
also optisch ist er super die zutaten
hat sich gleich zum auftakt mir sicher
dass auch fleisch sehr hoch qualitativ
ist aber dass irgendwie so weiß schlecht
so gepresst oder sowas einfach nicht so
nicht so sagt ich nicht so blöd nicht so
softly flavour auch nicht so
geschmeckt um das gegrillt ist und so
aber vom sc in werders
was sagst du wo die 5 wir wurden bisher
wirklich nur alle erwarten wurden
übertroffen bei den ponys jetzt auch
wieder aber der bürger ist möglich unter
den erwartungen geblieben oder die
sozusagen den sehen uns vielleicht
wieder verabschieden lassen das mal
sacken das leid also leute wer das
gedacht hättet ihr gedacht dass die
pizza zumindest für mich besser ist als
der bürger hätte es wirklich nicht
gedacht und die pommes wirklich die sind
jetzt noch in erinnerung ist eine woche
später nicht räumen wird immer noch von
diesen pommes aus dem burger restaurant
aber das mit dem fertig pettys hat
einfach nicht überzeugt pizzas bord war
dafür wirklich super und insgesamt
beides gute laden also wenn man so beide
lernen nimmt und in eine deutsche
großstadt pack sind beide top keine
frage aber man hat sehr hohe erwartungen
ich bin gespannt was ihr sagen werdet
könnt ihr meine meinung teilen was
würdet ihr lieber ausprobieren pizza
oder burger schreibt in die kommentare
und das allerwichtigste dann für eine
million a muss